bien peu ou pas du tout d'organisation
qui avait été jusque là voici un bureau
modèle aux yeux du gouvernement de dire
même les dirigeants vont être comme tous
les employés pas des espaces de bureaux
fermaient pas de poste attitré et ça
c'est une des conditions du succès de
cette vision immobilière low avec des
espaces ouverts et lumineux 100 places a
signé sans téléphone ni paperasse les
employés du bape bureau d'audiences
publiques en environnement sont parmi
les fonctionnaires les mieux outillés
pour un retour au travail dans le
concept de bureau known as ni nos
propres est évidemment très important
la souris avec la vie appartient chacun
donc chaque soir quand on finit quand le
travail
on part avec nos appareils les tables
sont exemptes de tout matériel dans le
fond il l'entretien ménager peut bien
nettoyer les surfaces
c'est aussi ce qui permet aux employés
de se tourner dans le télétravail
le bape compte 54 employés pourtant on
retrouve ici 36 postes de travail et 80%
des gens qui font du télétravail ou pas
déjà deux ou trois journées par semaine
plus besoin de grands locaux dans ses
nouveaux bureaux le bape occupe 40 %
moins d'espacé qu'avant ce qui a permis
de réduire le coût du loyer de 50 % une
économie de 250 mille dollars par année
le genre d'économie qui inspire le
gouvernement legault atteler travail des
des préjugés qu'on doit peut être passé
par dessus et maintenant que la pandémie
à dissiper les doutes face au
télétravail le président du conseil du
trésor sont plus que jamais pressé de
prendre le virage et de l'étendre à une
majorité de fonctionnaires ça fonctionne
très bien
alors donc pourquoi revenir à la même
façon de travailler moi je pense qu'au
contraire on va bénéficier si je peux
dire ça de la crise pour avoir testé des
choses on ne retournera plus je pense
comme avant à 1 5 jour bureau je pense
que tout le monde y compris pour les
syndicats il est clair que ces nouvelles
habitudes de travail vont tinter les
négociations en cours avec le
gouvernement
on a fait la démonstration que c'était
possible le gouvernement vienne
comprendre que c'est possible
le télétravail est donc là pour rester
dans la fonction publique et le retour
au travail servira de test
peut-être lesjak
enfin deux jours à télétravail puis
trois jours bureau ça serait peut-être
un arrangement qui serait correct mais
non on va tester ça dans les prochaines
semaines le retour des fonctionnaires
dans les tours à bureaux se fera au
compte gouttes et va s'échelonner sur
plusieurs mois et ce même au bape ou un
bureau sur deux demeurera inoccupés tant
que les mesures de distanciation seront
en vigueur ici valérie gamache radio
canada québec